You are a brand.
No matter what you think, when people hear your name,...
...they conjure up some association with it.
When people see you, an emotional response is evoked.
Like it or not, you, your good name,...
...and your reputation truly are a brand.
Does your brand shout "cutting-edge", "with it",...
..."original" and "revolutionary" or something else?
Some hip stylish and cool brands include Starbucks, Apple, Virgin and Prada.
Could you be a cool brand?
Do you want to be?
What would it take?
When people think of you, will words like...
..."innovative" or "world-class" or "unique" or "fresh" infuse their minds?
What would it take for you to become the Starbucks of your team...
...or the Apple of your workplace?
How could you become so strikingly great at what you do...
...and who you are and what you stand for...
... that everyone around you adores everything about you?
When asked what makes a cool brand, most people answer "authenticity,...
...originality, and uniqueness", but that's what they are striving for.
They don't want to be seen as having the same type of brands as everyone else.
Authenticity, originality and uniqueness.
So, if you want your personal brand to be embraced,...
...then be real, be honest, and be yourself.
If you or your company's brand doesn't inherently have these traits,...
...please, don't attempt to be cool.
You'll look like you're having a mid - life crisis, and you will be laughed at.